you guys ready for this one oh boy from
the daily mail
get vaccinated or stay in jail new york
judges order defendants to get coveted
19 shots as part of plea deals and bail
agreements but is it even legal
a new york judge ordered a defendant to
get the coven 19 vaccine as part of his
plea deal while another made it part of
a drug dealing suspect's bail terms
manhattan judge jed rakoff granted the
release of a woman accused of drug
dealing on the condition she get
vaccinated
another order came from bronx judge
jeffrey zimmerman who made vaccination
part of a plea deal
neither defendant appeared to object i
mean to be honest it's probably like
okay i get to go and you know that's all
i got to do the problem i have with this
is the setting the precedent of
government-mandated medication which we
already have with like fluoridation and
water and things like that
it should be between you and your doctor
so you go talk to your doctor
not have a judge tell you what you
should or shouldn't do right or you know
we have we have joe biden now check this
out
joe biden
is calling on corporations he tells
companies to start mandating vaccines in
speech celebrating the approval of the
pfizer vaccine hey that's great the fda
approved physical vaccine wonderful now
as same as it's always been you can go
talk to your healthcare professional
that you know and trust and figure out
what makes sense for you and don't ask
me for medical advice
but to tell all of the companies start
mandating this
we are going to see a purge
of sick people
and then what they go on unemployment
someone brought this up to me earlier
they said have you considered that with
new york mandating the vaccine with no
medical exemptions uh and now for
teachers as well and this this push from
big companies they're going to take all
of the people with medical conditions
that are still able to work and make
them unable to work and now they'll be
stuck on government benefits once again
just decimating the economy
what do you think is behind these
mandates i mean really because are we to
believe that you know uh joe biden's
saying that private companies have to do
this and judges saying that people have
to do this on conditions of their parole
are we to believe that this is the
result of a genuine concern for public
health oh is there something i
definitely don't think so so what is it
what is it is it just is it just power
that's uh i don't know man look at that
uh uh newsom you know he doesn't want to
do work
imagine being able to just like tell
everyone to do what they're told and
they do it
i think it's ideology
you know
so um
it's just
man it people want power
you know
it's like you ever play video game you
put in a cheat code um it's fun right
you're playing doom and you type id to
qd and then also you can just go around
doing whatever you want and it gets
boring kind of quick but that's
basically what they're doing they're
like oh now i can just snap my fingers
and it's done but these people are not
smart people
you know yeah like imagine
you hired a guy to fix your toilet and
he's a computer programmer
but you gave him carte blanche and you
come in your bathroom and just just
spraying water everywhere nothing makes
sense and he's like i'll you leave it at
me i'll figure it out it's like
oh dude yeah will you though will you
really
but you know what we we're on the middle
of nowhere now
that's why i don't know if i care
you know i mean like you've been saying
that for a while it's just like these
cities want to burn themselves down let
them do it you know i mean
if people aren't going to vote to recall
gavin newsom
then well there you go you
time to move right you know that's what
i'm saying people people were
complaining because i was because i'm
saying get out of cities and they're
like no you got to stay and fight and
i'm like listen
in new york city staying in fighting was
voting
and saying no to this and then they keep
electing democrats they elect joe biden
you did and they ref and and
if people didn't stand up in enough
numbers to actually make that change
then
you you did it you made your attempt and
now it's time to go i mean i suppose you
can try and stay but my point is like
if there's a bunch of people yelling
like hey we're gonna win if we all stick
together and then when it comes down to
it not enough people stick together
you tried
what more can you do
well there was that one restaurant tour
in new york i think he had a bakery and
he said that he's not gonna you know he
had that he put this big poster in his
window saying we don't discriminate
based on gender sex anything vaccinated
unvaccinated and they they put that
poster up right after um uh
it was uh de blasio right after de
blasio announced and they thought that
they would have like a lot of other
restaurants fall in line with them you
know and
say the same thing it's just like we're
not going to do this nobody did so now
they're just you know the only ones out
there saying we're not going to follow
this policy and we're probably going to
get charged thousands of dollars in
fines so even when you do step up and do
that you're not necessarily guaranteed
to have other people have that brave but
you shouldn't worry about what other
people are going to do in a certain to a
certain extent sure you should stand up
for what you believe in and if that
means in the end they'll uh delete your
restaurant it's worth it
it's worth it to me because we see
what's happening with these kids right
you see that video in australia where
the 12 year olds are getting pepper
sprayed and arrested
there you know there's a bunch of videos
that are like this of kids being
arrested there's a video out of
australia where it's a bunch of
teenagers partying like on the beach and
they get arrested and they get fined a
thousand bucks and it's like
to everybody who said to me oh i can't
speak up and risk my job because i have
to feed my kids and i'll be like okay
well you know good luck feeding them
when you're in a good luck because if
you don't speak up now hey it may be
harder right now
but it's going to get way way worse
i mean we're looking at the signs man
look at what's going on with australia
they're building quarantine camps
they're putting signs on people's houses
labeling them as you know unfit
undesirables
this same course this the same history
has happened over and over and over
again it's almost like you can just
track it to a beat
you know here we are in 2022
what was going on in the 20s leading up
in the 30s into the 40s
you know
people just go along with it
like your friend who was like cheering
for the fascism right right yeah yeah
totally fine with them but you know i
don't know enough about australia or
australian history to understand why
that place is the one that's actually
doing the full-on nazi lockdown they
gave up all their guns
oh oh that's that's what happened in
australia so uh what do you guys know
when australia gave up all their guns
they gave up all their guns a little
while ago and not that i think people
would go out and actually fight with
their government
the left tries to use as an argument
because they always want to jump to the
most extreme
if i say hey you know one of the first
things nazis nazis did was target
disabled people making it harder for
them to live discriminating against them
then people will go yeah but the nazis
also did most extreme thing ever and i'm
like yes that was bad that was really
bad one of the worst things in history
and they also did a bunch of other bad
things before that that led up to the
point where people accepted it it's
actually what gina carrano was saying
remember that post she made they got her
in trouble she was saying that they they
demonized people to the point where
neighbor attacked a neighbor and we've
got to resist that
they they took her job because of it yep
so we're walking into the exact same
thing it's it's one step at a time it's
not like you know that's what i always
say did you think the despots wouldn't
have an excuse
they're not just going to snap their
fingers and become authoritarians
overnight it looks like it was in 1996
there was a mass shooting in australia
and they restricted guns
so here's here's what happens when you
have guns
the government the the agents of the
state are scared to kick your door in
without a warrant huh
because you are legally allowed to
defend yourself brianna taylor's
boyfriend when they when the police
broke the door down
and they fired at him he fired back and
hit a car i think he fired first and him
in the leg they tried charging him with
it and he ultimately won in the case
there was no charges in the end because
he was legally allowed to defend himself
from someone breaking his door down
in australia new zealand canada and the
uk we got these videos of cops walking
in breaking the door down and just
coming in and beating people and
dragging them out
we don't see that in the united states
because the police are concerned the
citizen is probably armed
it's not that the citizen is going to
get in a gunfight no we don't want it to
happen it's that
if they don't do it properly
the power balance between the individual
and the states are
uh at that moment the same
in the uk the state always has the
advantage so don't give it to them why
why give the state the advantage
that's a big difference so i don't know
you know australia uh
people just slowly gave up more and more
their freedoms and while you weren't
looking nazis took over
so by allowing the government to take
their guns the government
just innately realized oh well now
what's the next step because it's it's
like you said it's not necessarily that
they were gonna you know use their guns
and arm in the streets and you know uh
it doesn't need to be intentional right
right it doesn't need to be intentional
it needs to just be that
uh
water flows
you know if you have uh uh
a river and there's a dam
and you open the dam the water pushes
through there's no conspiracy among the
water to make the water flow through
it's just the natural flow of things so
when you have governments that overreact
and are panicky and don't like an armed
citizenry
then you lose your guns
what happens when you have a population
with no weapons tyrannical government
easily just flows through those open
gates
so
you know a lot of people i think assume
that the quest to take guns away is on
purpose i don't necessarily think so i
think some for some people seasoned guns
is on purpose but i was i watched this
old like gun debate thing with rosie
o'donnell and tom uh tom selleck and
i've watched a bunch of other arguments
about the the 90s women's band stuff
like that
it's panic
it's it's people who don't know anything
about guns panicking and then virtue
signaling virtue signaling their way
into banning them
and then what happens when you have a
disarmed population
tyranny flows right through those open
gates
whether whether anyone wanted to happen
or not
look i don't know i don't know what you
think what you guys think about the
mandates and stuff i think if people
want to go get the vaccine it's their
business i just think excluding people
you know based on this stuff is
mandates are awesome in the right
circumstance i think this is the not the
right circumstance personally um
it's very exhausting to talk about this
stuff because
i don't know if screaming at a camera
is enough to get people to
to to change but other than that what
else is there i don't know you know self
self-improvement that's kind of the
route i'm going in my life right now
get better at singing get better at
thinking get better at typing
the uh the the vaccine manage they're
doing say that you have to have
for like you know the military is doing
it now too you have to have the you know
your vaccines have to be up to date
so i was uh actually this is really
really funny somebody
i tweeted vaxxer id as racist you see
the joke i'm making voter id is racist
you know vaxxer id and then what
happened was was actually kind of
surprising
the responses i got from democrats said
a vaccine card is not an id and i was
like what what are they talking about
i'm talking about de blasio requiring
ids to get into buildings
i didn't say vaccine cards had vaxxer id
like they're using the vaccine the the
vaccine mandate as a way to mandate
identification they didn't know it and
then when i actually told some people
like the mandate requires id this one
guy was like no it doesn't and i was
like did you read the mandate and he
goes yes and i was like then you didn't
read it
and so he was like show me where it says
that i send him the link
and then he comes back ten minutes later
and he's like oh wow i didn't see that
part where it says an id must be
government you know issued or whatever
and i'm like yes i'm talking about ids
they don't know god that could be a
mantra of the 49 of that first poll you
mentioned oh i didn't see that part that
could be like their
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you